Here's another great.
explanation of
the product of the prior and the
likelihood
a visual demonstration
before I discussed this graph
or this figure.
let me give you some background because this
figure is based on some analogy. And by the
way this book.
I don't have the physical copy with me right now. It's in
my office.
But this figure is from a very well written and
popular book on Bayesian statistics called.
statistical rethinking
a Bayesian course with examples in R and Stan
and this is specifically the second edition of this book.
And the author of the book is Richard Mac. Alright, so the
analogy the author gives us this suppose. You have
one of these model Globes.
You know the ones you find on.
And offices where they put it put them on the
desk.
and you want to use
the Bayesian intuition
for determining the proportion
Of land to Mass.
the planet Earth
and let's just say we know we are aliens. We
know nothing about the planet Earth.
We have no Factor figures.
And we want to figure this out.
What we do is you would we would pick up this.
globe
so you toss this little Global model into the air and then you catch it.
Okay.
You catch the globe.
And then you look at your index finger.
And see if under your finger you under in the index
finger.
Whether you find water.
or land
and then you write that down.
So let's look at this example.
so
the top we're looking at how many?
Oh whether our outcome is a water or land.
and
down here on the x-axis
you're asking about the plausibility of seeing water.
Now the dashed line represents.
the prior
our our prior distribution
So before we toss the globe at all,
it's still on the desk.
It's a flat.
Then we pick up the globe for the first time. We toss
it in the air that we catch it.
We catch it and then when we look under our right index
finger we find water.
So now the plausibility of seeing water goes up
to one.
So the assumption is we know 100% of
the land 100% of
the Earth is water.
But then we pick up the globe toss it again.
Look again. Look under our index finger and this time
you find land.
now the plausibility of seeing or the proportion
of
water to land is 50%
So one here represents.
Whether it's water or not.
And now it's gone down to 50% So it used to be 100% now.
It's gone down to 50% water. So it's
50% 9 50% water.
this is
You know two.
experiments into the
you know this exercise.
We toss the globe once again and this time when we
look under our index finger we find water.
So now the
plausibility
or rather the proportion of water is skewed
to the left, which me when we
say skewed left. We mean we mean this tail over here, right?
So the peak here is at the right,
but it's skewing to the left. So now it's more concentrated
towards water. So we
believe.
So far into our experiment.
That we have more water than we have land.
And that's the point right? So this was our prior distribution.
and after the new other experiment our
distribution has been changed. Oh, this
is our posterior in other words. So this is our prior distribution. And
now this is our posterior distribution. This is
the this is the intuition of Bayesian.
inference
We make assumptions.
And then given new evidence we update.
our assumptions
and we continue this way we keep on tossing the globe
costing the globe looking at whether it's water
or land until we've eventually after non-experiments. We
realize this is the proportion
of land to water. So we have more water than
we have land.
in practice
in a real world environment or in a real
environment.
your priors
could come from
pre-existing
information
it could be expert data. It could be.
It could be data that existed before you begin
your statistical statistical study.
But you have some idea you have some prior
distribution.
And then as you gather new data.
which will
be evidence.
You will proceed to update your distributions.